[Music]
you
mmm-hmm hey welcome my name is Peter pet
we go to pax excellent say hi everyone
[Music]
hey that's my [ __ ] collector's item
now we're going to the convention and
now wait we're not we're going to the
slam
oh yeah Jackson dr. Weston come oh wait
I can't tell you to come watch because
it's already good what are you doing
stop I'm very happy another pegs yeah I
mean I really enjoyed that
[Music]
you get some good shots yeah am I ready
for my close family anymore it's good
Michael such a cutie are you here behind
the camera Phoenix to get back I put all
that you put everything but everything
how I mean we're taking over the blog
now AJ today what some eye cream
PewDiePie subscribe to markiplier Jake
oh you're welcome welcome welcome
welcome it's in your day it's in your
side I hope you're enjoying this vlog
that it has nothing to do with me so far
we're gonna I don't know where you fell
Michael from you what are we doing today
no I meant like oh the other days okay
whatever surprised me
I'm gonna do a lie detector test I'm
scared it's gonna be [ __ ] don't say
I can can we stop
cinnamon toast can my mortal enemy it
looks like you're wrapped up in a tight
situation all right
so Ken I'm gonna ask you some questions
you better not be like
if you lie you will get pine but if you
tell the truth you get to pie me do you
have a secret crush on another youtuber
that's a lie right and you know me know
I knew uh-oh
that's real nice that's right yeah the
truth finally caught now jacksepticeye
it's about to get pudy pie I learned
something about myself today crazy oh my
god
you look insane Michael let me see
myself ok so now I'm going to meet up
with some make-a-wish people and then we
do the panel and then it'll be great
awesome yeah so I have the channel now
it's mine sorry Felix I took it over
we're walking around text Syl I'm much
better at vlogging than Felix is anyway
he sucks at it he never he never
interacts I see somebody already said
right bye
see they didn't say hi Felix did they
know this it hijack suck it
welcome to the vlog again this is the
stage of course every element has
I'm excited yeah I'm excited yeah it's
an [ __ ] the hater you keep dancing me
all the time Irish [ __ ] [ __ ] no
actually I just an errand for my
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
the question party was so good
right
[Music]
so this is packs I had a lot of fun I
want to give a huge shout out to all the
cool people I don't know why shout out
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
everyone is really cool I had a lot of
fun because I got to meet friends and
[ __ ] I know I have friends is weird
right pax was great they did a great job
great convention they made sure we had
fun and I'm gonna go back to this group
of people so I'm gonna [ __ ] I don't
really like him I got a pimple really
brewing up there yeah it was really fun
I hope you enjoyed the vlog if you
didn't leave a like subscribe to become
a bro if you haven't let me know if you
want more vlogs I always appreciate the
feedback and and brofist what happened
ah legit
I've got a [ __ ] stick you better not
touch my man cuz I gotta stop by the way
[Music]
is scary yours I'm not a Bailey hey wrap
him up you can get in good put it here
in the space dragon yeah
slay this even run away